For all the action, mistakes, easter eggs
and cameos in blockbuster movies, the drama
and comedy behind the scenes can be just as
awesome.
We're changing things up, and giving you a
rapid fire dose of movie trivia you never
thought to look for.
Screen Rant presents: Know Your Movies: 20
Amazing Movie Secrets That Will Blow Your
Mind!
Jurassic World
The product placement in the Jurassic Park
sequel stuck out like a sore thumb - but it
wasn't the studio's work.
The director actually requested the sponsors,
claiming that if the park were opened today,
every part of it would be branded.
The Avengers: Age of Ultron
The final battle is set in Sokovia, but it
was filmed at a London police training college.
The statue in the town square was given a
fake beard, since it's a well-known monument
to Robert Peel, the inventor of the modern
police force, and the reason British cops
are still called "bobbies."
Furious Seven (NOT "7")
The director James Wan ("Juan") confused everyone
when he said that the seven in the title was
the WORD, not the movie's place in the series.
Why?
Apparently the movie's title is actually a
tribute to the classic Japanese movie Seven
Samurai, with Wan seeing Dominic Toretto and
his team as Hollywood's modern - horsepowered
- Samurai.
The Martian
The secret NASA mission to save a stranded
astronaut is given the title "Project Elrond,"
a reference to a secret meeting in The Lord
of the Rings.
When Ridley Scott realized Sean Bean was actually
IN that movie scene, and would also explain
the name in this film, he wanted to change
it.
But the crew demanded it stay, since the joke
was actually a hilarious coincidence.
Mission: Impossible - Rogue Nation
Tom Cruise is famous for doing his own massive
stunts, climbing skyscrapers or hanging onto
an airplane.
But the actor's training even covers the stunt
driving in Rogue Nation.
It wasn't to meet the star's demands, either
- the stunt coordinator claimed he didn't
have a stunt driver who was better than Cruise.
Star Wars Episode VII: The Force Awakens
Back in 1983, when interviewed about Return
Of The Jedi, Mark Hamill gave an interview
to TV-AM in the UK and told reporters George
Lucas spoke of bringing Luke Skywalker back
as an Obi-Wan type character training a new
generation of Jedi in Episode VII.
He also said Episode VII wouldn’t happen
until 2011…
Ant-Man
Any superhero actor has to hit the gym before
shooting their scenes, but apparently, Paul
Rudd was more committed to getting into shape
than Marvel expected.
When they started shooting, the Ant-Man costume
had to be altered to compensate for Rudd's
added muscle and lost fat.
And an unscripted shirtless scene was added
shortly after.
Mad Max: Fury Road
The villain of Fury Road is larger than life
in every way - except for the weapon he seems
to be praying to.
That's an authentic Australian waddy, a weapon
used as recently as World War I.
When the actor's mother-in-law left it to
him, he asked the director to work it into
the movie, and the rest is history.
Guardians of the Galaxy
Marvel may be churning out blockbusters, but
they don't spend money if they don't have
to.
The massive set constructed for the Kyln prison
in Guardians of the Galaxy was so expensive
to build, the studio only agreed to foot the
bill after planning to melt down all the steel
after filming, and sell it back to the supplier.
Captain America: The Winter Soldier
The Nick Fury chase scene through city streets
was a hit with fans because it actually seemed
realistic - but they didn't know just how
realistic it was.
The sequence was based on a 2010 Brazilian
police chase that looks exactly the same,
and the directors even played the police video
as part of their original pitch to Marvel.
The LEGO Movie
A major highlight of the movie is Liam Neeson's
role as both Good Cop and Bad Cop.
The directors wanted to record them separately,
but Neeson thought it would be better to rapidly
switch from one to the other.
The result was a crazed, manic split-personality
filled with improvisation - and fans loved
every second.
X-Men: Days of Future Past
The movie that rebooted the X-Men movie universe
had it all: new mutants, returning favorites...
even a romance between Wolverine and Storm.
The future scene was deleted, but it showed
the movie versions of the heroes finally gave
in to their attraction like they had multiple
times in the comics.
Maybe the second time is the charm.
Dawn of the Planet of The Apes
The movie's original ending saw the apes watching
as battleships approached in San Francisco
Bay, promising an imminent war.
Director Matt Reeves decided to go with a
more emotional ending between the movie's
ape and human leads.
It's a incredible ending scene, even though
it was filmed weeks before release, Reeves
directing via Skype, and a stand-in for Andy
Serkis' actually on set.
The Amazing Spider-Man 2
It may have killed Sony's solo Spider-Man
series, but the original ending would have
had fans talking for years.
Peter's father Richard Parker coming back
from the dead is one thing, but showing Venom
in OsCorp's basement - along with the frozen
head of Norman Osborn - leaves every fan with
unanswered questions of what would have come
next.
Gone Girl
In all the suspense and twists and turns of
this story, audiences probably missed some
time-consuming CG effects.
According to director David Fincher, with
the number and variety of wigs that star Rosamund
Pike had to wear, there isn't a single shot
of her in the movie that didn't require a
special effects team to retouch her hairline.
Who knew to even look?
Man of Steel
When Henry Cavill showed up for his Superman
screen test, the prototype costume wasn't
available - so they used the classic Christopher
Reeve version instead.
When Cavill stepped out of wardrobe in the
brightly coloured, outdated suit with bright
red underwear, and everyone on set grew quiet,
he knew he had found the man for the job.
Interstellar
The sprawling corn field used in just a few
scenes required 500 acres to be planted and
grown.
It might sound like insanity on Christopher
Nolan's part, but when shooting wrapped, the
corn was sold - for a hefty profit.
Frozen
Most fans know this Disney hit is based on
"The Snow Queen" by Hans Christian Andersen.
But the main characters' names are no coincidence.
Say them out loud fast enough, and "Hans,
Kristoff, Anna, Sven" is clearly a play on
the author's name that few will catch on their
own.
Jurassic Park
Director Steven Spielberg had young actresses
record blood-curdling screams to see how they'd
handle the movie's terrifying twists.
When he played actress Ariana Richards' tape,
and it was the only recorded Scream to raise
his wife from bed in a panic, he realized
he had found his Lex.
Those are some of our favorite mind blowing
movie facts, but let us know which ones we
missed and stay tuned for more!
And remember to subscribe to our channel for
more videos like this one.